[Musica]
racconta me cosa che facevano sarà la
piccola piccola figlia piccola mi
ricordo quando aveva 34 anni riguardava
spesso e volentieri il cielo è tanto è
vero che una volta il nonno mi ha detto
questo è che questa piccola mi fa delle
domande quel non so rispondere che
genere di domande ho detto io
vuoi sapere perchè vediamo la lunga
anche di giorno
e allora il nono rispondere perché ciò
che la illumina ma la nota è più
luminosa e non c'è mica sole alla notte
oppure chiedeva perché la luna oggi eco
a durante il giorno
ecco a sé e l'altro ieri era da
tutt'altra parte
cammina la luna le versa per lasciarla
lumer camera ecco come ogni bambino sin
da tre anni le mie preoccupazioni sono
state le passeggiate della luna delle
stelle nel cielo ed è incredibile
pensare che proprio quello che gli occhi
di un bambino possono vedere è stato per
lungo tempo per millenni
l'unico mezzo concesso all'essere umano
per esplorare l'universo l'universo a
quegli occhi appariva come universo
limitato statico immobile e soltanto con
poche piccole eccezioni come per esempio
accade nel 1054 quando astronomi cinesi
riportano l'apparizione di una stella
brillantissima nel cielo
la stella rimane visibile in pieno
giorno per due settimane ad occhio nudo
di notte per due anni la stella poi
scompare misteriosamente
tanto che gli astronomi cinesi la
chiamano stella ospite nel cielo questa
idea di universo statico e
imperturbabile viene superata nel 1610
quando proprio qui a padova un
professore dell'università pubblica il
primo trattato scientifico di astronomia
si intitola sidereus nuncius ovvero il
messaggero celeste
il trattato parla delle sue scoperte
fatte con un telescopio il primo
strumento per osservare l'universo e
questo trattato ci fa scoprire i crateri
della luna
i satelliti di giove le nebulose
planetarie di fatto il telescopio
diventa la nostra prima finestra
nell'universo e la luce visibile il
fotone diventa il nostro primo
messaggero celeste che siamo in grado di
decodificare
questa è la presa rappresenta la nascita
dell'astronomia moderna
tuttavia sappiamo che i fotoni della
luce visibile
sono soltanto un piccolo tassello di
tutto lo spettro elettromagnetico che
abbiamo a disposizione
cosa sarebbe se potessimo per esempio
osservare la radiazione nella lunghezza
d'onda del radio delle microonde
nell'altro violetto la gx la giraffa
quello che abbiamo fatto dal 1600 non è
stato altro che continuare a suonare lo
stesso tasto del fiamme porte ascoltare
la stessa nota come sarebbe la melodia
se potessimo ascoltare tutto lo spettro
elettromagnetico
beh dal 1900 possiamo farlo
ora abbiamo una flotta di strumenti in
orbita in terra è a disposizione della
nella a terra per ascoltare e osservare
il nostro universo è questa flotta di
strumenti questo avanzamento tecnologico
ci ha portato ben oltre le stelle ci ha
portato per esempio a osservare il primo
buco nero
questa è la prima foto di un buco nero
scattata da terra al mondo
sento qualcuno qualche dice che ha un po
sfocata beh sì effettivamente avete
ragione un po sfocata
ok allora il vostro telefonino fa foto
migliori giusto vi faccio un esempio
prendiamo un'arancia mettiamo l'arancio
sulla luna poi prendete di nuovo il
vostro telefonino e provate a fare la
foto della lancia da terra col
telefonino
ok quel questa è la sfida che i colleghi
dell'evento horizon telescope hanno
affrontato e hanno vinto perché questa
rancia che è un buco nero si trova in
una galassia distante 55 milioni di anni
luce dalla terra
m.it seven ok
vi porta indietro alla mia domanda
iniziale come sarebbe lo spettro il
nostro universo se potessimo se vuole
tutti i colori dello spettro
elettromagnetico ascoltare tutte le
frequenze d'onda
oggi non possiamo rispondere a cui
stiamo rispondere a questa domanda molto
semplicemente guardando indietro in
quella regione del cielo dove nel 1054
mille anni fa a pari con quella stella
luminosa
se oggi puntiamo i nostri telescopi in
quella direzione
quello che appare incredibile questo è
quello che vediamo adesso ogni immagine
ogni colore
ogni dettaglio è stato ottenuto con
telescopi e che osservano in a frequenze
diverse quindi i fotoni di energia
diversa ci portano informazioni dettagli
di queste sorgenti astrofisiche diverse
uniche
oggi scopriamo che questa non era una
stella mila anni fa non hanno visto una
stella era l'esplosione di una stella
quello che noi chiamiamo oggi supernova
quello che noi oggi osserviamo è il
remnant quello che rimane della
supernova i resti e questa è la
bellissima nuvolosa del granchio la
carne bull a oggi di fatto abbiamo
accesso a tutto lo spettro
elettromagnetico
ma il 1900 oltre a questi avanzamenti
tecnologici e la conquista dello spettro
elettromagnetico
c'è anche lasciato con altre cose da
scoprire in particolare nel 1915
scusate nel 1915 albert einstein
ipotizza il fatto che ogni corpo dotato
di massa deforma influenza lo spazio
circostante va inizio a quello che viene
chiamato poi gravitational wave istream
la storia delle onde gravitazionali e di
fatto dall'inizio anche alla teoria dei
buchi neri
in quegli stessi anni
i fisici hanno un grosso problema si
sparge la voce di una certa particella
fantasma una particella che nessuno può
osservare il problema che avevano i
fisici in quegli anni era che osservando
un particolare decadimento radioattivo
chiamato decadimento beta quello che
vedevano anche questo decadimento
violava la legge di conservazione
dell'energia legge che tuttora di
conforto è ancora immutabile
alla fine a un certo punto forza di
rompersi la testa non capivano cosa
succedesse a un certo punto wolfram
paoli dice ok qui sarebbe un rimedio
disperato come l'ha definito lui
qualcosa che un fisico teorico non
dovrebbe mai fare
ipotizza l'esistenza di una particella
che non potrà mai essere osservata
questa particella è quella che si porta
di all'energia questa idea viene poi
abbracciata dal fisico enrico fermi
il quale conia il termine di neutrino
per definire questa particella neutrino
perché è piccola inosservabile è neutra
priva di carica
altra la difficoltà per osservarla
sorprendente ma oggi sappiamo che i
neutrini sono le particelle di materia
più abbondanti nel nostro universo nella
terra ci sono miliardi milioni di
neutrini che continuamente
l'attraversano possiamo fare un semplice
esperimento si è alzata il vostro
pollice posso dirvi esattamente quanti
neutri stanno passando in questo istante
perfetto ora posso contare è al secondo
abbiamo 65 milioni di neutrini che
stanno attraversando il vostro pollice
al secondo
tutto a posto come non avete problemi
giusto 65 milioni di partizioni di
altissima energia che attraversano ma
non avete alcun problema
questa è proprio la caratteristica dei
neutrini interagiscono pochissimo con la
materia
l'unico modo che hanno di interagire con
la materia è quando un neutrino va a
sbattere contro gli atomi di qualcosa
per esempio se il vostro corpo fosse un
detector uno strumento capace di
osservare i neutrini registreremmo una
collisione di un neutrino con un atomo
del vostro corpo ogni mille anni
da qui stiamo tranquilli non c'è
neutrini arrivano sulla terra passano
attraverso la terra attraverso di noi ma
non ci fanno nulla
ecco il mistero di neutrini è legato ad
un mii stare un po più grande e per
questo mistero
devo raccontarvi del nostro quarto
messaggero
tornando indietro sempre dal 1900
l'austriaco victor esso prende il suo
strumento lo mette dentro un cestino di
una mongolfiera
lo porta a 5.000 metri sopra il cielo e
si accorge che c'è una variazione
intensissima che proviene dal di fuori
della nostra atmosfera non viene da
terra viene da fuori dall'universo da
molto più distante
questa radiazione oggi sappiamo si
chiama raggi cosmici i raggi cosmici
sono particelle pesanti per esempio
idrogeno o atomi che continuamente
bombardano la nostra terra sono
particelle cariche quindi dotate di
carica elettrica e di fatto quando
percorrono il loro percorso di un
universo vengono deviati dal momento in
cui vengono originati al momento in cui
origina raggiungono la terra i raggi
cosmici
beh non sono come i neutrini questa è
un'immagine che ho scelto per
rappresentare i raggi cosmici un mazinga
con gli occhi distruttivi che
continuamente osserva la terra e la
bombetta
eh sì perché se indagi cosmici
arrivassero a terra la vita non
esisterebbe i vostri telefonini
andrebbero in tilt tutta la tecnologia
che abbiamo andrebbe distrutta questa è
la potentissima radiazione distruttiva
con cui abbiamo a che fare e
continuamente bombarda la terra per
fortuna o rimedio è rimedio si chiama
atmosfera terrestre
quello che succede in sostanza i raggi
cosmici arrivano verso la terra ma
penetrando attraverso l'atmosfera
interagiscono con gli atomi
dell'atmosfera
per farla breve si rompono perdere un
energia tanto che quando arrivano a
terra sono praticamente innocui
rimane tuttavia il ministero di dove
venga originata questa potentissima
negazione di raggi cosmici neutrini
elettromagnetica in qualche angolo del
nostro universo
noi sappiamo che esistono acceleratori
di particelle che possono raggiungere
energie molto maggiori di quelle che noi
esseri umani
potremmo mai raggiungere per esempio
molto maggiore di quelli del large
hadron collider al cern il più potente
acceleratore di particelle costruito
dall'essere umano
per rispondere a questo mistero per
fortuna oggi abbiamo fatto anche
avanzamenti tecnologici e dagli anni
abbiamo finalmente iniziato ad ascoltare
le onde gravitazionali grazie ad
esperimenti come l'aygo virgo abbiamo
iniziato ad osservare i raggi cosmici
come per esempio con l'osservatorio
piero dice in argentina localizzato a
1400 metri da terra e abbiamo iniziato a
osservare il passaggio di neutrini tra i
ghiacci dell'antartico come per esempio
con lo strumento ice cube la sfida che
abbiamo oggi di fronte è avere tutti
questi messaggeri in mano poterli usare
in pratica in sostanza la rinascita
dell'astrofisica e cercare di combinare
insieme tutti questi messaggeri ed è un
piacere potervi raccontare da
protagonista una storia una prima sfida
che abbiamo vinto questa sfida inizia
qualche milione di anni fa
queste sono le nostre i nostri
tempistiche 5 milioni anni fa qualcosa
di incredibile successo in un angolo del
nostro universo è questa esclusione
questa cosa incredibile ha generato un
fascio di raggi gamma di radi i raggi
cosmici molto probabilmente questi però
non hanno raggiunto la terra ma sono
stati generati insieme a neutrini
i neutrini hanno viaggiato nel loro
percorso che lungo la universo verso
terra e sono stati accompagnati da un
fascio di raggi gamma
uno di questi neutrini è finito in
l'antartico e li entrerà tra i ghiacci
dell'antartico è andato a sbattere
contro proprio uno degli atomi del
ghiaccio e questo ha generato questo ha
generato un segnale ragazze c'è un
problema questo segnale
ha segnato un segnale cosiddetta di luce
cerenkov che poi è stato segnalato dal
lo strumento ice cube immediatamente ice
cube ha diramato un'allerta tutto il
mondo osservatore in tutto il mondo da
terra da spazio hanno guardato le
ragioni del cielo da cui questo neutrino
proveniva a caccia di questo
acceleratore cosmico che non si sa cosa
sia il primo che è riuscito ad osservare
una sorgente consistente con questo
neutrino è stato il satellite spaziale
fermi che ha trovato una sorgente gamma
di radiazione gamma posizionamente
consistente con questa neutrino abbiamo
scoperto che questo ha reso questa
sorgente non è una sorgente qualunque è
un buco nero ospitato all'interno di una
galassia al centro di una galassia
questo buco nero interagisce con la
materia della galassia de fato
proiettando un fascio di neutrini
probabilmente raggi cosmici e anche
radiazione elettromagnetica e questo
fascio punta verso la terra questa è una
delle prime storie che possiamo
raccontarvi in questo secolo che da
inizio un po la rinascita
dall'astrofisica o forse come la
preferisco chiamare io la rivoluzione
dell'astrofisica e sono certa che nei
prossimi anni molte altre storie come
queste saranno possibili raccontare e
per ora non mi resta che augurarvi in
the molti messo in terapia
grazie
[Applauso]